アロハー
ああ
あっはぁ本日は日本の皆さんはじめ社長
です
先生宅入っていまぁ公庫
いくどこにいると思いますかん
ドガーン度意味がわかりますこれはハワイ
に来ておりません
[音楽]
鳥がもう大歓声あげてるよありがとう
みんな
あるいはの鳥の雛入りがさあ
q 翌日はですねー
どんなときは3日目くらい三日月3日め
んって結構実は今ハワイに来ておりまして
いいですけどバカンス
林たね
プロットフラップ排気ちょっと三瀬税の
クラートハワイっちゃった感じでございは
本当に
西郷
上田のしっ
何だろう
[音楽]
ブーブー日本人少ないというかあっあれよ
ねっ広げて
ゆっくりはいで生活させていただいて持っ
ています日本の皆さんに一言いいですか皆
さんにしたことですよねぇー
世界見た方がいいです
ありがとうございますみると思うんです
けど本当に海がきれいでもマッソー
めっちゃ綺麗だってるー
10キロとする橋町猪狩色なんだという
ことであのもちろんフラットなのファン
言ってるわけなんですけどもちょっと
ついでにと言いますからとはある目的の
ために打つサングラスけどいい
まぶい
いいやもう mabo いいねうふふ
ちょっと折角来たらということですね
ちょっと水で2棟ある目的のためにハワイ
に来ておりますネップいるとかあります
けどねうんこれドーンとは思われるかと
いうと思いますけどちゃんと理由があり
ますのでそれ後々の動画でて見て
いただけると嬉しいですっっ
2年間留学しますまってまってまだまだ
レッドあれって以上使用可能編成か俺いい
です
か ak きっちもうちょっと意味が
わからないよもうすごいねあるものは
ラッキー
できますか
バットもイカバターいうわけでせっかく
ハワイに来てるわけなんで
ちょっといろいろ見ていきたいとおもい
ます
ん
はいというわけで
[音楽]
は感じですねあっはっいまの異教の生き物
で凄い凄い損益はねめっちゃ緑たことで見
たことないれっに練ってれ得あるかなガー
ですねこれは
含めてみてくださいマネージャーが捕まえ
てみてくださいって言ってるんですよ
お客様の主婦現地の人からジョインターが
僕
大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫ございます
ポン酢でお好きならアンペア何か良い減っ
本だと思わないである展望台ですね恋高い
ところで景色が胸を張っ綺麗です
見て
うわあああああ
を入れるのって
いやー
[音楽]
すごいいいねまずで
ブーブー
矢部と割と大事ですかね good
morning つってもらうと思います
ねまずで8日ねっ
ん
[音楽]
全然酔わんやんふれふれ言え全然4 a
ブーバーで見たらああああよかっすごいだ
しもうねぇ
青がきれずいて後からが白買おう
あれ
[音楽]
う
ぜ
[音楽]
いいねぇいいですねん
母は言ったんですよ
おいたんか
持つっ
ワン
ちゃん
ano
デー
あっはい酒飲みに行くかー
[音楽]